support the production of more videos by
visiting the support move section on our
website the link is in the description
below thank you and enjoy so next up if
you recall we said that atoms of an
element are defined by their atomic
number which was the number of protons
that Adam contained in other words all
atoms of an element are identical
identical in their atomic number in the
number of protons right those first two
sentences same thing however the mass
number which is equal to the number of
protons plus the number of neutrons can
be different for some atoms of the same
element a same elephant the same element
different mass number which means that
atoms of the same element can vary in
the number of neutrons they have right
because if the mass number is equal to
the number of protons plus the number of
neutrons and the mass number can change
but the proton right the number of
protons cannot change then the number of
neutrons must be able to change okay so
that's what you have an isotope isotopes
of an element have the same atomic
number right which makes it the same
time same element but they have
different mass numbers right so they
have different numbers of neutrons so
let's consider our first example here of
carbon with carbon there are three
naturally occurring isotopes there are
more isotopes of carbon that have been
synthesized laboratories but we're just
going to consider the naturally
occurring isotopes so you can see here
they all have different mass numbers 12
13 and 14 all right but they're all
carbon right so the number of protons
they have is equal is equal across the
board right they all have six protons
right and I can put that six here right
as the atomic number right so the number
of neutrons they all have would you take
the mass number minus the number of
protons so 12-6 in this first
six 13-6 would be seven 14-6 would be
eight now the percent abundance
basically what that is is how much of
the naturally occurring isotope on earth
is that particular isotope so for carbon
12 we've got ninety nine point eight
nine percent ninety nine point eight
nine percent of naturally occurring
carbon is carbon 12 which is almost all
of it carbon 13 is 1.1 one percent that
pretty much accounts for essentially all
of it but in a very very small
percentage is is carbon 14 okay so these
are all isotopes of carbon naturally
occurring specifically so a question
that often comes up is we've got these
different isotopes of the same element
but how do their chemical reactivities
compare right do they all react
different to that same and the answer is
that they pretty much the same they
react chemically pretty much the same
and that's because chemical reactivity
is not dependent on the number of
neutrons it's dependent on the number of
electrons will talk more about that
later however what they do differ in
terms of reactivity is their nuclear
reactivity and that's because neutrons
and protons are both in the nucleus of
atoms and the nucleus there are certain
reactions of the nucleus that's what
we're talking about when we talk about
nuclear reactivity that can change
things right but as long as these have
the same number of electrons then
they'll react the same way okay now i do
want to bring up another example just
because this kind of comes up from time
to time especially in organic chemistry
in some other areas of general chemistry
so we got hydrogen okay naturally soup
naturally occurring isotopes of hydrogen
with mass number of one two and three
respectively we got protium deuterium
and tritium again respectively so they
all have their all hydrogens so the
number of protons is the same for all 31
the number of neutrons will be their
mass number
minus their atomic number so 1 minus 1
here is 0 2 minus 1 is 1 3 minus 1 is 2
percent abundance here ninety-nine point
nine eight five percent of this first
one protium often sometimes just mostly
referred to as just hydrogen by the way
deuterium is about Oh point zero one
five percent and then a really really
really tiny amount of of tritium exists
one thing I do want to mention though is
that deuterium sometimes is referred to
as just D right if it's not written as 2
H like this it can be just D that comes
up pretty often in organic chemistry
it's not be able surprisingly enough
donut to actually know that it's just a
heavier version of hydrogen and then
tritium sometimes is referred to as T if
it's not 3h but I will say that this one
comes up much less often yeah so I hope
that video was helpful in kind of
defining isotopes and describe
discussing a little bit about percent
abundance so thank you for watching if
you found that video helpful don't
forget to hit it with a like and
subscribe for more content also followed
with University on the different social
media links in the description below
thanks and happy study